بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله والصلاه
الصلاه والسلام على رسول الله
وعلى اله واصح واصحابه اجمعين
اما بعد
فالكلام موصول في الوجيز في كتاب الطهاره
في ابواب المسح على الخفين
ووصلنا فيه الى باب ما يبطل
المسح
لاحظوا اللفظ باب ما يبطل المسح
وليس ما يبطل الوضوء باب ما يبطل الوضوء
قد سبق نحن الان نتكلم عن ما يبطل المسح
يعني ينتهي المسح باحد هذه الامور اذا
ظهرت
‏So we are continuing in the chapter of
wiping over a person's footwear over
socks, over shoes, over leather mocasin
etc.
‏And
we are now at the final junction in this
chapter and because of
this chapter is seen to be seen to be
perceived to be by some as being more
complex more difficult than it actually
is.
‏few
and think we have that
now the takes us into the finalch here
which is what will end or what will
nullfy
wiping over the notice the wording we're
not saying what will nullify the w
that came by way of wiping over
‏nullify the wi
point caner
over mywe I take my
sock shoes what have you off and wash my
feet one of three things
three things that will invalidate
the wiping not the
number one
انقضاء المده
[Silence]
‏Now again this is not invalidation of
the
is invalidation of the wiing
when I put on a pair of socks let say
and I have and I put these socks on
and then I break my wood and I wipe over
these socks next time I make now is when
the times 24 hour
time
24 hours 23 hours and I make over them I
could have as long as my last but next
time I go to make I cann what I cannip
over them
يقول انقضاء المده لان المسح مؤقت كما
علمت فلا يجوز الزياده على المده المقرره
جنابه
number جنابه
[Silence]
الجنابه لحديث صفوان كان رسول الله صلى
الله عليه وسلم سبق هذا الحديث يامرنا اذا
كنا سفرا الا ننزع خفافنا خفافنا ثلاثه
ايام ولياليهن
الا من جنابه لكن من غائط وبول ونوم
والحديث عند الترمذي
والنسائي واحمد
جنابه
نزع الممسوح عليه من الرجلين
‏before I can take as much
wakes up
put on socks and hours latang
socks hasn't broken can take and put
‏Now in order to
they have to
pair on. Now what about if we have
layers on? Let say we have shoes socks,
and on to of them shoes.
‏lay
in layer lay that is
right say super cold person puts on one
pair of sock pair of sock three pair of
socks five pair of socks
and
‏pair of shoes and a pair of rubber
boots outside of the shoes. This guy
really wants to keep his feet warm. They
go to make where does he wipe? He wipes
on what?
The boots the outside.
‏Now he takes off the first pair of
boots, the shoes, the fifth pair of
socks, the fourth pair of socks, the
third pair of socks, the second pair of
socks, the first pair of socks. Still he
can wi the last pair of socks now they
have invalidated
the the mess. Understood? So wiping is
on the outerm and the ruling is
connected to what? The innerm.
جنابه
يقول المؤلف فائده انقضاء المده ونزع
الممسوح وهذه الاشياء قد سبق ذكرها
وبيانها لكن نذ نقراها من باب الحاجه او
من باب الفائده وايضا من باب ال
الاستطراد يقول فائده انقضاء المده ونزع
الممسوح عليه يبطلان المسح وحده فلا يجوز
المسح حتى يتوضا ويغسل رجليه ثم يلبس لكنه
اذا كان متوضئا حين نزع الممسوح عليه او
انقضاء المده فانه باق على وضوئه يصلي به
ما شاء حتى يحدث يقول فائده من لبس جوربين
على طهاره ثم مسح عليهما ونزع الاعلى بعد
المسح جاز له اتمام المده بالمسح على
الاسفل لانه يصدق عليه انه ادخل رجليه
طاهرتين اما اذا لبس جوربا واحدا ومسح
عليه ثم لبس عليه غيره لم يمسح عليه لانه
لم يصدق عليه انه ادخلهما طاهرتين والحديث
وهذا كلام
لبعض العلماء المعاصرين
رحمه الله تعالى
[Silence]
ان
الغسل
نسال الله سبحانه وتعالى ان يفقهنا في
ديننا نساله تعالى ان يتقبلنا ولا يردنا
نساله سبحانه ان يجعل دعائنا دعاء مقبولا
ونعوذ به سبحانه من عين لا تدمع وبطن لا
يشبع ودعاء لا يستجاب له وعلم لا ينفع
اللهم طهر قلوبنا من الادران والاحقاد
اللهم ربنا
اغفر لنا ولاخواننا الذين سبقونا بالايمان
ولا تجعل في قلوبنا غلا للذين امنوا ربنا
انك رؤوف رحيم والله اعلم وصلى الله وسلم
على نبينا